Um, yeah, I'm just about done with this quarantine. You know what I mean?
Not for real. I understand I'm going to do what everybody's doing.
How about that? I'm going to do what everybody's doing. That's the thing.
Quarantine is the most. If you can't beat them, join them scenario.
I have ever heard. All right. It's like, all right,
everyone's staying endorsed that. Guess what? Your boy's staying in doors,
but you starting to protest. You're starting to go out. What are the, who?
The rules for that. All right. it. Fine. it. If we're all getting,
we're getting it. You're all getting it.
You're all shaking hands and holding the hands and protest right there.
Holding hands and protests. Why do you have to hold?
What if the rubbish and everyone's faces? Just protests.
Just be like open it up, open it up, open up the country. Open it up. But dude,
um, I'm if you guys, if you can't beat, 'em join. 'em fine.
If everyone's gonna be driving around, getting the done. All right,
let's go get this. Let's go get this, dude.
Let's get it, dude. Come on doorways and let's get it.
Now. I lied. I been just panicking, but you know,
what are we gonna, what am I going to be? What am I going to be?
One of the only guys sitting in his house, chilling,
trying to knock at that Rony virus,
everyone out there going to incubus, concerts and. And I'm over here.
Just not Torin, not making those bags short.
I make the podcast sponsor bag. I'll make the road bags.
That's my bread and butter baby. I swear to God, dude,
after this quarantine is over one thing, the quarantine is made me learn.
And I'm telling you, and I know this isn't relatable and you know what, dude,
I don't give a. I'll tell you this much, dude,
I'm spending money like a do to the second.
This quarantine ends. I go out and I spend money.
I bring stacks of cash.
Like I'm see murder or master P.
And I just sh I just show up at places by and dude straight up.
it. And I go like this. How much?
Oh, I do it, dude. And then I go to another store.
Okay. No problem, dude. I'm spending money. I'm getting, cause here's the thing,
man. I would be like, nah, I don't know if I want to spend,
I don't know if I'm going to get that guy. I got the chain, you know,
it costs some money. I bought that a little bit a while ago.
I should probably not buy the watch dude.
When quarantine is over and your boy's on the road, he's getting that watch,
bro. You think I won't be different.
You think I won't be different when the quarantine ends. Holy, bro.
I'll be so different. You'd think I'm Asian. I don't give a F I sorta got,
I'll be shorter. I'll be a different person. I'll be wearing bandanas.
And I just where's this. What am I doing? How we live in?
I'm cooped up in my house. I didn't get my kitchen done. Oh, what bro.
When this core team, when Trump goes quarantines over,
I go bring them dudes. We're doing the kitchen.
I'm going on tour doing the I'm redoing rooms that I don't even need to redo.
I'm getting chimneys, all sorts of chimneys on the top of my house.
I don't even have fireplaces. I'll get them. People are like,
but you don't have a fireplace. I'd be like, I'll get them later. it.
Put a chimney up.
Why do I have the money for what all I'm doing is Postmates and,
and watching Netflix.
I can't wait to spend those monies jackets, dude.
It'll be summertime. Next year. Jackets upon jackets,
iced out gold teeth, pulling up in something.
So foreign it's unreal something. So they'd be like, where's that from?
I'll be like, Oh, it's from a country. They just started.
There's only five guys there. What? Yeah, I know.
They just make cars. This is one of them. Wow. What color is that?
They didn't come out yet. See you later.
I'll do that. skid. That where you buck twice before you go,
you think I do one no way I go.
I go like that dude. And I take off an airplane and said, take off like this,
these. I don't do these anymore. I don't need to run away, dude.
I do like the GI Joe where the things go. And then I go. Or,
or, or I cartoon it. I get an airplane that takes off like this,
like that dude, like a.
And I ride to the next destination like this wreck, like the road runner.
You think I won't do it. I'm saying it now. So, you know,
when I show up with a Bedazzler green Cape with a collar that goes higher than
my head and uh, and a medallion over the thing that has a big C on it.
You don't say, well, what happened to Chris? Because you know.
Wow.
Let's go out, let's get this Corona virus all become immune.
And then spend this money after we could get jobs again,
because what are we doing with all this? What are we doing? I, you know,
I look at people live hand in mouth. I get it. But you know, it's like.
That's 150 degrees.
It's all good, man. But I'm spending that money and Mark my words,
kind bars out the, just all of them all. And it's not even expensive,
but like people are like,
why does he feel his car with so many boxes of kind bars? It's like, well,
because he just spends money. That's it. And he doesn't want to talk about it.
What's that? You know? And the car, the car is something far into it.
It's a new country. I will do that. And I can't wait.
I can't wait, me off. Just started making money.
And then the whole world shuts down. Ah, but it's not relatable. Whatever,
dude, listen to NPR. If you want to be relatable, dude, this about this cult.
I got to start watching Waco. I got to start watching Waco.
Pick up some tidbits. Play with that.
That guy Taylor
Hankins or whatever the his name is Taylor kitsch.
Hagans hitch Taylor kitsch guys.
Good looking bro. You think you're good looking, bro. All right. I see you,
dude. I saw you once out. Not even in LA.
Forget where I think I was in Nashville. I don't remember where the I was,
but I was there to do it.
And I saw you with five dudes and you were the best looking one, but dude,
that doesn't phase me. That doesn't phase me. I have a personality. Okay. Any,
I look like a big bird, but it's all good, man.
So you're going to walk in the room, dude. Taylor Henkins.
You're just going to walk in the room. Okay. All right.
All right.
Uh.
He cuts his hair,
he cuts his hair and does a mullet and looks better.
How he doesn't Theo did it and looked like a lesbian. He does it.
It looks better somehow and puts on some funky glasses and does Waco.
And you look better, dude.
I'll fight you until my last breath. And it'll be way before your last breath,
by the way, my wind is not good. But um, so, uh, anyway,
let's do some ads, man. See,
these nighttime episodes are firing on all cylinders, not syllables. Whoa.
I said it right. I keep saying firing on all syllables.
It's firing on all cylinders. And I know that and I kept saying it.
I was having a brain fart anyway. Um,
w where do I get these ads? See, that's the thing.
I opened up too many tabs and then, I was looking at Yeezy's dude.
I'm 40. Saw some guy was like, dress your age, bro.
When the are you supposed to what? 19 year olds are making money.
I just started making money. I'll be buying the. That's fresh.
Cause I want to look fresh and bro, on that, let's not forget.
I'm the youngest man alive, bro. Y'all. Um,